demain c'est le cas évidemment qu'il
faut le dénoncer mais un peu de
subtilité s'il te plaît différence entre
être au courant que c'est un homme à
femmes puisque konami maladie c'est
autorisé et c'est un violeur il n'a pas
dit france au mali il y avait un gars
qui avaient été déposées pour viale
d'accord mais très bien est ce qu'il a
dit à bild j'y suis tous les noms
arrêtez-moi plein qui d'abord m on voit
bien dans envoyé spécial que les filles
et les jeunes femmes ne parle pas parce
qu'elles sont souvent prises parce
qu'elles ont peur parce qu'il est connu
parce qu'il est influent et donc ça on
voit bien qu'elles ont besoin de 10 ans
de 15 ans de 20 ans et après ben voilà
c'est ya prescription donc ça je trouve
qu'on le sent bien et moi j'ai trouvé
pardon mais l'article de paris match
très intéressant parce que comme vous
l'avez dit fatima et gilles on voit la
toile d'araignée on voit les petits
arrangements entre amis c'est à dire que
il ya un côté on est clément on est
indulgent on est sous on est aveugle on
est à musique oui mais on prend pour et
à qui on prenne un fait acquis tous ces
témoignages c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de procès équitables n'y a
pas de contrat dire que toutes ces
seules toutes ses salles de
l'agglo et ce n'est pas qu'elles mentent
mais on prend pour fait acquis c'est à
dire est ce que c'est à la presse
aujourd'hui d'instruire un procès c'est
la question qu'on connaît
vous estimez vous que la presse est en
train d'instruire un procès où est ce
que la presse simplement est en train de
mettre à jour quelque chose qu'on avait
le titre c'est homer tard c'est à dire
qu'on a des mis sous le tapis est donc
en train de libérer une parole et en
même temps donne la parole aux anneaux
de nicolas hulot tiendront ce dont tous
ces procès instruisent forcément un
charge quand on n'entend pas la parole
de l'autre on instruit à charge la vie
sans gêne dit allez je remets en cause
la parole de l'autre je dis simplement
que dans un procès équitable on entend
les deux parents n'étaient que
ce qui m'interpelle mais malgré tout
c'est que on a le sentiment que d'un
côté on nous dit tout le monde savait et
de l'autre côté ce qu'on interroge dix
personnes savaient donc de mise en cause
par image pardon par image qui compte
parmi les plus grands journalistes vous
pensez vraiment qu'à paris march qui
connaît par coeur le système qu'une
somme de dossiers invraisemblable et
savait pas on ne vous l'a dit ce hacker
où dsk ne serait complète là dessus
germaine prendra en marche mais paris
match je suis désolé savait aussi si
tout le monde savait paris match j'avais
encore plus que tout le monde en métal
assez drôle tout le monde c est ce que
c'est pas tout le monde soupçonnait même
temps quand on soupçonne quelqu'un
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire quoi
enfin comment vous voulez dénoncer 15
vous arrivez à jamais même s'il monte en
votant pas moi j'aime bien donner je
trouve qu'il ya toujours autant de
cynisme c'est à dire que le problème des
gens est de savoir ce que nicolas hulot
d'abord et est l'une des personnes les
plus populaires de france est la
question que se posent les gens surtout
en ce moment c est ce qui nous dérange
ou est ce qu'on en a encore besoin mais
la réalité c'est que vous avez quand
même des gens qui ont porté plainte vous
avez comme une fille qui était biolay
qui attend depuis des années qu'il se
passe quelque chose il ne se passe rien
et aujourd'hui on est en train de parler
de plusieurs autres femmes donc on peut
pas faire le truc comme si rien
n'existait bien moment donné ça existe
et heureusement qu'on en parle enfin
parce que sinon on n'aurait jamais parlé